THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
>> YOU CAN KIND OF FEEL IT.
RIGHT?
THE WEATHER IS CHANGING.
FALL IS RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE FALL OF
THE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S BEEN A TERRIBLE, AWFUL WEEK
FOR THEM.
CAPPED OFF BY A MISERABLE
THREE-HOUR DEBATE ON ABC.
FIRST, THERE ARE SIGNS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WILL GIVE TRUMP A WIN.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO DO THIS.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE TRUMP
A WIN.
AND I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
ALLOW A VOTE ON THAT U.S. MCA --
THE NEW U.S.-MEXICO-CANADA FREE
TRADE DEAL.
EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST," I
ALMOST FELL OVER WHEN I READ
THIS, SAID IT'S A NO-BRAINER.
BRING THE THING UP FOR A VOTE.
SECOND THING IT'S BEEN A
BAD WEEK FOR THE DEMOCRATS, THE
DOW IS NOW UP AROUND 27,000, THE
S&P IS AT 3,000.
WELL, THAT'S NEAR RECORD
TERRITORY FOR THE DOW.
UP FOR THE EIGHTH STRAIGHT DAY.
NOW, WHAT DOES THIS INDICATE?
RENEWED OPTIMISM AMONG CONSUMERS
AND BUSINESSES.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TOWARD THE
CLOSE OF THIS YEAR.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM,
STILL OPEN TO A TRADE DEAL WITH
CHINA.
A TIGHT LABOR MARKET HERE AT
HOME, THAT MEANS WAGES
CONTINUE -- SEE, A LITTLE BIT OF
AN UPTICK.
THAT'S ALL GOOD NEWS.
I LOVE A TIGHT LABOR MARKET.
THIRD, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NO
ANSWER FOR TRUMP ON THE ECONOMY.
INSTEAD, WHAT YOU HEARD IN LAST
NIGHT'S DEBATE WAS THE SAME
TIRED PLATITUDES.
>> WE CAN USE TRADE TO HELP
BUILD A STRONGER ECONOMY.
>> WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
CREATING THE ECONOMY THAT WORKS
FOR ALL OF US, NOT 1%.
>> THE GOAL OF MY CAMPAIGN IS TO
MAKE THIS AN ECONOMY THAT ALLOWS
US TO LIVE OUR HUMAN VALUES AND
ASPIRATIONS.
>> Laura: WE'RE DOING THAT.
IN A FEW MOMENTS, WITHE EEL
ANALYZE THE DEBATE WITH THE ONLY
WAY IT MAKES SENSE, BY THE WAY,
BRUTAL SATIRE.
BUT FIRST, LET ME SAY NO ONE ON
THAT STAGE LOOKED STRONG ENOUGH
TO BEAT TRUMP IN 2020.
I DON'T WANT TO GET TOO
CONFIDENT.
TO USE ANOTHER TIRED ANALOGY.
BUT THEY JUST DID NOT LOOK LIKE
THEY WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
STAND ON THE STAGE AND DEBATE
THIS PRESIDENT ON HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE
LEADING THE PACK STILL, AFTER
ALL OF THEIR EFFORTS TO TAKE
THEM DOWN, COULD BARELY STRING
TOGETHER TWO COHERENT SENTENCES.
>> I'M THE GUY THAT BROUGHT THE
BRADY BILL INTO FOCUS AND BECAME
LAW.
I'VE BEEN IN AND OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN NOT WITH A GUN.
THREE DIFFERENT COUNTRIES,
PAKISTAN OWNS THE THREE
COUNTY -- THE COUNTIES RUN IT.
I'LL GO ON AND ON.
I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: WOW -- HE'S NO LONGER
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
BUT IT FELT GOOD TO SAY THAT,
I'M SURE.
ALL OF THE DEMOCRATS ON STAGE
DEMONSTRATED IN ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER THAT THEY'RE SIMPLY NOT
COMPETENT TO GOVERN, EVEN
LIBERALS KNOW THIS ISN'T
WORKING.
THE LEFTY PUBLICATION, "SLATE"
EVISCERATED BIDEN'S ANSWER ON
THE QUESTION OF REPARATIONS.
AND ALL "SLATE" DID WAS MERELY
PUBLISH BIDEN'S INCOHERENT
ANSWER IN FULL.
AND WHEN ABC MODERATORS RAISED
THE ISSUE OF TRADE, EVERYONE ON
STAGE, EXCEPT ANDREW YANG, WAS
CAUGHT STUMBLING OR RESPONDED
AGAIN WITH MEANINGLESS BROMIDES.
THEY LOOKED LIKE THEY WERE KIND
OF 7th GRADERS SHOCKED ABOUT A
SURPRISE QUESTION THAT THE
TEACHER DROPPED IN ON A HISTORY
EXAM.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
ELIZABETH WARREN, SHE SAID
PROUDLY THAT SHE'S GOING TO BAN
ALL FRAKING.
GOOD LUCK WINNING TEXAS WITH
THAT POSITION, LIZ.
BETO'S GUN BUYBACK, A GUN BAN
SPELLED DIFFERENTLY.
NOT HAPPENING.
AND BERNIE SANDERS, HE ALWAYS
SEEMED ANGRY.
HE KIND OF LOOKS LIKE HE BELONGS
TO THAT WALDORF IN THE MUPPETS.
THAT'S A GOOD LOOK.
ALL KIDDING ASIDE, THIS IS OUR
FUTURE.
THIS IS OUR LIVES.
THIS AMERICA, THE MONEY THAT
EVERYBODY HAS EARNED, LOOKED SO
HARD TO EARN IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS, DO I THINK AMERICANS ARE
GOING TO TURN THAT ALL OVER, ALL
OF THOSE GANGS, TO, WHAT?
ELIZABETH WARREN AND HER GREEN
RAW NEW DEAL.
OR LET JULIAN "LET THEM ALL IN"
CASTRO THROW OPEN THE COUNTRY'S
BORDERS?
NO WAY.
COMPARE TRUMP'S RECORD OF PEACE
AND PROSPERITY TO WHAT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY HAPPEN IF ONE OF THE
TOP DEM CONTENDERS WIN.
I HAVE TO SAY, I DON'T THINK
IT'S EVEN CLOSE.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW A LOT
ABOUT POLITICS ARE SURE --
THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY SURE THAT
TRUMP'S PERSONALITY, HIS TWEETS,
AND HIS TONE, IT'S ALL GOING TO
SINK HIM.
HE'S TOO ABRASIVE, TOO COCKY.
HE SWINGS AT TOO MANY PITCHES,
BLAH, BLAH.
ALL I'LL SAY ABOUT THAT IS A LOT
OF PEOPLE -- THEY DON'T LIKE
BILL BELICHICK EITHER.
HE'S GRUFF.
HE DOESN'T SMILE MUCH.
BUT GUESS WHAT, BELICHICK WINS
AND WINS AND WINS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO LIKE THEM,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE WINS.
THE TRUTH IS, OBAMA REALLY WAS A
GREAT POLITICIAN.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THAT.
TERRIFIC.
CAPTIVATED A CROWD.
NONE OF THE DEMS RUNNING NOW
REALLY ARE.
IT'S NOT IN THEIR FAULT, IT'S
NOT IN THEIR DNA, IT'S NOT IN
THEIR SKILL SET.
WHAT DO THESE FOLKS DO?
JOE BIDEN SHOULD MOVE ON.
WRITE HIS MEMOIR, TELL OLD YARNS
ABOUT HIS LIFE AS A SENATE OR
GROWING UP AS A YOUNG BOY.
MAYOR PETE, HE CAN GO BACK TO
SOUTH BEND AND FIX THE HORRIBLE
CRIME PROBLEM THERE.
AND THEN ELIZABETH WARREN, SHE
CAN GO BACK TO THE SEQUESTERED
LIFE ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS, MAYBE
DO SOME DNA RESEARCH.
BERNIE SANDER, HE SHOULD JUST
LEAVE POLITICS AND RUN ONE OF
THOSE FREE SOCIALIST CIRCULARS
THAT GET AT THE SUPERMARKET
RAILS AGAINST CORRUPT LOCAL
POLITICIANS, ALWAYS STACKED UP.
AND MAYBE JULIAN CASTRO CAN
ASSIST MIGRANT FAMILIES AT THE
BORDERS.
A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE THERE.
AND COREY BOOKER, HE CAN START
HIS OWN VEGAN YOUTUBE CHANNEL,
BIG BUSINESS THERE.
AMY CLOBECHAR SHOULD BE A
PARTNER AT A BIG LAW FIRM AND
START ORDERING ASSOCIATES
AROUND.
KAMELA HARRIS, SHE WOULD BE A
GOOD PRESIDENT, AT LIKE A SMALL
LIBERAL ARTS COLLEGE.
OR MAYBE SHE'D BE A GOODLOE CALL
TELEVISION ANCHOR.
I COULD SEE THAT.
BETO OROURKE SHOULD RUN A SCHOOL
OF ROCK FRANCHISE.
HE HAS A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
THAT ARENA.
BUT NONE OF THEM, AND I MEAN